if i had created a website with this
many problems i'd kill myself do you
have a question kelly yeah i have a lot
of questions number one how dare you
yay
kevin
woohoo
for kevin for sneaking up
hey i haven't gotten one yet
yeah yes i have not gotten one either
so keep going
[Music]
down right all right all right all right
okay all right we'll keep them crawling
okay this is the fine work award this
goes to stanley for all the fine work
you did this year
you know you did
[Music]
last year i got great work so i don't
so i don't know what to think about this
award
but at least i didn't get smelliest
bowel movement like kevin
and this next award is going out to our
own little pam beasley i think we all
know what award pam is going to be
getting this year
it is the whitest sneakers award because
she always has the whitest tennis shoes
on
down oh here we
[Applause]
many people go thank for this award
okay first off my kids
because i couldn't have done it without
them
thank you
let's give michael a round of applause
for emceeing tonight because
this is a lot harder than it looks
and also because of dwight too
um
so
finally i want to thank god
because god gave me this dundee
and i feel god in this chili's tonight
thank you
[Laughter]
take a break wake up
wait here let me help you dwight okay
get up get the bath yeah just keep them
away it smells like chicken soup i know
i have to go to the hospital i know
where are we going i just want to say
goodbye okay i'll be back yes i know but
it's going to be different why
it's just hard to explain oh pam you're
adorable oh my goodness
come here oh
doggy hugs
shotgun
you don't think you should sit in the
back with dwight
the rules of shotgun are very simple and
very clear the first person to shout
shotgun when you're within the side of
the car gets the front seat
that's how the game's played
there are no exceptions for someone with
a concussion
oh god a minivan
what is meredith's problem
well i think she has a kid yeah she has
one kid no husband she's not going to
find one driving this thing around
where are you going
all right
get inside where are we going we're
going to chuck e cheese chuck e cheese
oh i'm so sick of chuck e cheese
going to the hospital michael i know i'm
saying
dwight what are you drinking i found it
under the seat oh my god dwight put that
down
give the bottle to michael no give the
bottle of michael give it to me
just keep your eyes on the road give me
the bottle or you're fired you can't
fire me i don't work in this van give it
to me dwight no give me the bottle will
you stop give me the bottle stop just
give it michael stop stop stop it stop
breathing stop give me the bottle stop
stop spraying me give me the bottle i'm
going to give you a little blast from
the past of michael gary scott when he
was a child star
and a show that you might remember
called fundal bundle okay without
further ado ryan
are you ready
that is miss trudy can't tell from her
costume but she had an amazing body
okay you can
fast forward
and
hey what's your name my name's chet well
hi chet is that chet montgomery uh i
don't i don't know that is his favorite
meteorologist
checking in with chet doppler's up
i
i want to be on tv
and he is on tv now everybody please
shut up please so you don't miss it
okay next show what's your name that's
me
oh hi michael i'm ed
well what's your favorite subject in
school
recess recess
so tell me what do you want to be when
you grow up
i want to be married and have a hundred
kids so i can have a hundred friends and
no one can say no to being my friend
uh
oh okay well uh nice talking with you
michael uh back to you miss trudy
actually
it's kind of too bad we're not coming
into work tomorrow why i bet michael had
some elaborate theme party planned like
scrambled eggs saturday
we're like hey everyone let's get your
boss late saturday
i have an announcement uh to make
i
am moving to costa rica
thought about it
for a long time now
and i'm finally gonna do it
so
i'm just gonna hop the fence and jog
home now
i just want to say how happy we are that
all of you are here tonight and i want
to especially thank those of you who
have traveled from far away to be here
with us tonight
especially the florida cousins
who obviously can't take a hint
four years ago i was just a guy who had
a crush on a girl who had a boyfriend
and
i had to do the hardest thing that i've
ever had to do which was just to
wait
uh don't get me wrong i flirted with her
pam i can now admit in front of friends
and family that i do know how to make a
photocopy
i didn't need your help that many times
and uh do you remember how long it took
you to teach me how to drive stick like
a year
i've been driving stick since high
school so
yes yes
for a really long time that's all i had
i just had little moments with a girl
who saw me as a friend
and
a lot of people told me i was crazy to
wait this long for a date with a girl
who i worked with but i think
even then i knew that
i was waiting for my wife
so
i would like to propose a toast
so if you'd all raise your glasses not
pam for obvious reasons but everyone
else if you would raise your glasses
what's obvious why can't pam drink
pam can't drink who i didn't i shouldn't
have said that i don't know why i did
she can do whatever she wants
though she shouldn't
she shouldn't because she's an alcoholic
pam is an alcoholic yeah that's not true
i no the
what we wanted the real the real reason
is that um
the pam's pregnant um
okay okay okay
hey
what i think jim is trying to say is
that
they had an accident and you know what
these two people they're living together
they are having lots of consensual sex
they were living together yes yes they
were living yes and you know what you
can't
expect them to be careful every time
because frankly it's just a different
sensation michael when you come well am
i wrong they say it's not different but
it's a different sensation oh my god
when you use
something to block
yeah i think everybody knows what i am
talking about it's not necessarily
different for the woman
but it is different okay okay okay
michael for the stop all right
my point is
i said what i wanted to say and mima i
hope you heard every word
all right
chip
two waiting
ready
you